while everyone knows Aragorn is awesome
it turns out that he actually had quite
an impressive resume before the entire
one ring business even kicked off if
you've ever wondered what he was up to
in the years before the Lord of the
Rings
keep watching to understand how this
Ranger from the wilderness winds up
claiming the throne of the kingdom you
first got to back up about six thousand
years at the beginning of the Second Age
a kingdom of men was founded on the
island of númenor to the west of the
coasts of middle-earth
the first of the kings of the
númenóreans was a man named el ros the
brother of Elrond of Rivendell while
Elrond famously chose to live in a
mortal life el Rose ops to live out his
life as a mortal man bellerose was the
first of a long line of Kings that rules
Numenor for over 3,000 years even when
the powerful island nation was destroyed
the bloodline continued to rule over the
offshoot kingdoms of Gondor and Arnor on
the mainland eventually though the
family line faded into oblivion ruling a
scattered people under the title of The
Chieftains of the Doudna Dayne in Gondor
the last king of the bloodline died a
thousand years before the Lord of the
Rings takes place leaving the stewards
in charge of the kingdom until a king
should come and reclaim the throne this
is what leads to the steward Denethor
leading the city when it's attacked in
Return of the King in the north though
there are no stewards to serve as
long-term placeholders instead the
kingdom of Arnor is completely destroyed
in reaction to this the surviving
members of the royal family and their
descendants eventually head into a sort
of semi exile under the new title of the
chief danes of the Doudna Dane under
this new name the chieftains rule over
the scattered remnants of their people
who quietly fight against the Dark Lord
as Rangers the chief danes of the Doudna
Dane rule for a thousand years before
the last one
Aragorn arrives on the scene as the last
century of the Third Age begins
aragorn's parents era thorne and Gil
Hren get married and little baby Aragorn
is born one short year later two years
after that his father is shot through
the eye with an arrow while helping
Elrond sons fight orcs
this leaves toddler Aragorn as the new
heir to the thrones of the kingdom of
Gondor and are norm naturally this isn't
a great position to
ian's since aragorn's people aren't able
to properly defend him and Sauron has
servants specifically trying to hunt
down and kill off the bloodline so his
distant relative Elrond agrees to take
in the child and his mother in Rivendell
Elrond comes to love Aragorn as his
adoptive son he gives him the name Estel
which means hope
and he keeps the young númenórean in the
dark regarding his lineage for a long
time it isn't until the boy turns 20
that the elven Lord feels his ward is
ready for the responsibility at that
point he tells him his true name and
title when Elrond tells Aragorn who he
is he also takes the opportunity to give
him some of the heirlooms of his
ancestors the most important of these is
the shards of narsil the splintered
pieces of a sword that had belonged to
aragorn's ancestors for thousands of
years aragorn's ancestor lndia had used
it in battle against Sauron but he'd
been defeated and the sword had been
broken
however lndia son is sealed or used the
broken pieces to strike out in
desperation cutting off the ring in the
process after that the sword shards had
been carefully preserved as an heirloom
of the royal house Aragorn would
eventually use the reforged sword in
battle against Sauron during the Lord of
the Rings at 20 years old
Aragorn is doing pretty well for himself
he already has a reputation in battle
and he's just found out that he's the
heir to not one but two Thrones the day
after Elrond tells him who he really is
he heads out into the woods strolling
along and singing to himself as he walks
he suddenly runs into a beautiful elf
maiden whom he's never met before
Aragorn introduces himself and finds out
that the elven woman is none other than
Elrond daughter
Arwen and yes that does make them very
distant relatives at this point Arwen is
nearly three millennia old and she's
regarded as one of the most beautiful
elves that ever lived in middle-earth
age differences aside it's love at first
sight for the young man his mother warns
him that as a mortal man he's aiming way
above his pay grade
Elrond recognizes the lovesick glances
in his face
- and isn't too happy about it however
he tells Aragorn that they'll leave the
matter for another day and the forlorn
Ranger leaves Rivendell soon afterward
when Aragorn leaves Rivendell he heads
into some of the wilder regions of
middle-earth here he spends the next few
decades developing his skills as a
ranger just a few short years into his
wanderings Aragorn meets Gandalf the
Grey the wizard and the exiled King
become fast friends and they even head
out on several journeys together while
Aragorn is already a good warrior at
this point the relationship with Gandalf
helps the young man learn a good deal of
wisdom - eventually the pair of
Wanderers begin to travel together less
often but they're well established
friendship carries on over the years
until they find themselves once again
side by side as the events of The Lord
of the Rings unfold aragorn's first
visit to the green fields of Rohan takes
place during the reign of theoden's
father Fane goal while very little is
reported about his specific actions it's
said in the appendix of The Return of
the King that Aragorn fights in feign
goals armies on top of that Aragorn
tells a homer in the two towers that I
have been in this land before more than
once and ridden with the host of the
Rohirrim
though under other name and in other
guys however for all of his time spent
in Rohan the real action doesn't pick up
until he heads south into Gondor once
again though as in Rohan he goes under
another name he's one of them
dangerous folk they are wandering the
wilds what he's reaping is I've never
heard that round ear he's known as
Strider one of aragorn's most triumphant
moments in The Return of the King comes
when he captures the fleet of black
ships and uses them to arrive at the
battle of the pelennor fields just in
the nick of time however it turns out
that this isn't the first time he's
tangled with these piratical foes of
Gondor the first time happened way back
when he was still a youngster
after serving King Fingal of Rohan
Aragorn heads south in order to pay
Gondor a visit at the time he goes by
the name of thor angle which means eagle
of the star using the secret identity he
becomes a valued advisor and ally of the
steward of Gondor XLE on the second at
the time the maritime people of invar
are threatening Gondor with their black
ships and the young advisor offers to
deal with the problem I do not know what
strength is like that I swear to you
with the blessing of the steward
Aragorn gathers a small fleet and sails
to unbar where he arrives at night and
burns most of their ships
Aragorn himself kills their leader in
single combat and then successfully
withdraws his tiny Armada with just a
few casualties while Aragorn is spending
time in Gondor as Thorin Gil he has a
notable run-in with the stewards son
Denethor just four years away from
becoming the steward himself Denethor is
one of the few GaN Dorian's who's not
enamored with the mysterious Savior from
the north the situation isn't helped by
the fact that even though denethor is
the heir to his father's stewardship
everyone seems to elevate the disguised
Aragorn above him this is no mere Ranger
he is article son of Arathorn
you will even Denethor zone dad appears
to put him second to the wandering hero
which may go a long way in explaining
his future behavior toward his own son
faramir the greatest issue between the
two men though comes in the form of
their wizardly affiliations Denethor is
a supporter of Saruman while Aragorn is
team Gandalf of course Aragorn isn't
ready to reclaim the throne yet so
instead of heading for Menace Tirith he
leaves Gondor before Denethor becomes
the steward however rumors later spread
that before he left
Denethor figured out aragorn's true
identity instead of going to menace
Terrace after the raid on Umar Aragorn
says farewell to his future subjects and
abruptly takes off travelling towards
Sal Ron's domain while scarce on details
of aragorn's adventures the appendix of
The Return of the King tells us that he
passed out of the knowledge of men of
the West and went alone far into the
east and deep into the south exploring
the hearts of men both evil and good and
uncovering the plots and devices of the
servants of Sauron and at the Council of
Elrond
Aragorn explains the leagues that lie
between here and Gondor are a small part
in the count of my journeys basically
after his epic deeds with the RO Hyrum
and the men of Gondor Aragorn disappears
from the history books while the details
are virtually non-existent over the
following years he wanders across the
lands of middle-earth learning about its
people and studying saurons plans after
aragorn's adventures in Rohan Gondor and
the lands beyond he stops by Lothlorien
to get some well-earned rest and it's
been nearly thirty years since he first
left Rivendell at this point and he's
almost fifty years old he matured quite
a bit during this time thanks largely to
his wanderings along with the fact that
the line of númenórean Kings live very
long lives and don't fully mature until
well into their first century you cannot
be 18
eighty-seven aragorn happens to arrive
in law Florian right when Arwen is there
visiting her grandmother Galadriel the
two reunite in the golden wood and this
time Aragorn isn't the only one feeling
lovestruck rather than seeing him as a
young buck head-over-heels in love
our whanau sees this young king in exile
as a sober mature man and the two
seriously fall in love when Elrond hears
about it he reluctantly gives his
permission to the match but he says they
can only marry if Aragorn defeats Sauron
and becomes King we don't hear much
about Aragorn specific activities for
quite a while after the events in
Lothlorien at some point he visits Moria
although he doesn't love the experience
calling his memory of the place very
evil he shows up one more time before
the Fellowship of the Ring
not long after Bilbo's birthday party
Aragorn agrees to help Gandalf hunt down
the mischievous Gollum while he fails to
find the tortured creature before Gollum
is captured by Sauron and leaks some
important information about the Shire
Aragorn does eventually track Gollum
down he catches him on the edges of the
Dead Marshes the two don't get on very
well as Gollum bites his captor leaving
Aragorn to roughly gag him and lead him
on a leash according to his arrangement
with Gandalf the Ranger takes Gollum on
a long trek north to Mirkwood where he
leaves him in prison for the wizard to
question later the next time we see
Aragorn is in Bri during the Fellowship
of the Ring during the story told in The
Lord of the Rings
Aragorn proves himself worthy of the
crowns of Gondor and our Noir and
ultimately becomes the king of both
kingdoms his success opens the door for
him to finally marry Arwen and the two
become king and queen of the ancient
realms
Aragorn rules the reunited kingdom under
the name Elessar which means elf stone
for 120 years during this time he
restores or thank the tower that had
been flooded by the ents and he names
fara mere the Prince of aphelion he also
reaffirms the alliance with King eomer
of Rohan and declares the Shire to be
free land under his protection
eventually at the ripe old age of 210
Aragorn becomes weary and willingly
surrenders his life bringing an end to
his long and illustrious career in
middle-earth
Arwen dies in the following year from
grief and their son becomes the new king
of the reunited realm check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the belt so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]